Emily Blunt is starring in one of the
Summer's biggest movies and after that
she's taking a break for a while here's
why the British actress revealed in
conversation with Bruce bossy on his
podcast table for two that she's set to
take some time away from acting now that
her latest movie Oppenheimer is set to
release soon blunt appears in
Christopher Nolan's latest epic as
Catherine Oppenheimer wife to Killian
Murphy's J Robert Oppenheimer and
apparently that'll be her last role for
the next year
blunt has two daughters a seven-year-old
Violet and nine-year-old Hazel with
their husband John Krasinski and as she
told bossy she wants to enjoy their
childhood more fully this year I'm not
working I worked quite a bit last year
and my oldest baby is nine so we're in
the last year of single digits and I
just feel like there are cornerstones to
their day that are so important when
they're little she continued and it's
will you wake me up when you take me to
school will you pick me up will you put
me to bed right
and I just need to be there ultimately
blunt said she feels guilty about
potentially missing her daughter's
childhoods and she thinks that's common
for moms she added on the podcast and I
think maybe all mothers are you're just
prone to feeling bad for God forbid
wanting something outside of being a
mother blunt was clear about wanting to
take time away from acting so she could
spend more time with her daughters and
it definitely doesn't seem like she
wants them to follow her lead and become
actors themselves in a June interview
with Harper's bizarre UK ahead of the
release of Oppenheimer blunt revealed my
toes curl when people tell me my
daughter wants to be an actress I want
to say don't do it because it's a hard
industry and it can be very
disappointing a lot of people tell you
not to take things personally but it's
completely personal especially when
you're being judged on how you look so
you just have to endure that side of
things it's clear that blunt like many
women in the public eye trying to
balance successful careers in Parenthood
is frustrated by the notion that you
can't have it all even though she's
unequivocal about this break from acting
she's also as ambitious as ever
acknowledging to Harper's Bazaar that
she's pleased that equal pay has become
a bigger discussion in Hollywood blunt
said ambition is healthy it shouldn't be
seen as a negative thing it's about
knowing your worth and what you bring to
a project and never apologizing for
doing well when all is said and done it
seems fair to say that blunt deserves a
break considering just how many projects
she's filmed lately she stars in the
Amazon mini-series the English and
Beyond Oppenheimer blunt has several
major movies already banked later in
2023 her film pain Hustlers which tells
the dark story of the modern
pharmaceutical industry arrives in
theaters her action thriller alongside
Ryan Gosling David leeches the Fall Guy
is set to release in 2024 with blunt
playing the ex-girlfriend to Gosling
stuntman who's trying to direct her own
film within the film she's also
reuniting with Krasinski for The
Ensemble comedy if which is slated for a
spring 2024 release and features a
packed cast including Fiona Shaw Bobby
Moynihan Steve Carell Phoebe Waller
bridge and more speaking of Crescent
there are always whisperings about a
third Quiet Place movie and blunt has
starred in both of the films a spin-off
prequel starring Lupita nyango a quiet
place day one is on the way but as far
as the mainline franchise goes nothing's
been announced yet for now though blunt
has more than earned her time away from
acting though audiences will undoubtedly
be happy whenever she chooses to return
foreign